donc on était les héros d'hier pendant
le coc vide on était tout seul tout beau
et tout mais là on est juste des déchets
qu'on va mettre dans le caniveau
je pense que maintenant il faut qu'ils
comprennent que d'appauvrir notre
fonction publique qui pour ça s'arrête
[Musique]
mais il va nous retirer huit jours de
congés annuels il va nous retirer aussi
certains de nos repos tout ça sans
compensation et sans gain financier
aussi qu'un syndicat qui a été reçu ce
matin pour environ deux heures et aucune
avancée 0 pneus les gars continuent à
l'intérieur de d'occuper pour un
complice à être de nouveau reçu pour
leur faire voir qu'on n'est pas prêt de
lâcher le morceau
[Musique]